how's it going bros my name is Priya ah
and with me is today we're gonna play
some games and we're gonna start off
with a great game are you excited yeah
so excited of carrots and blood of
carrots and blood we're gonna play off
carrots and blood let's do this alright
and the blue one we have to just pull
this out whatsoever so we have to forget
it
I know you go there go there and see me
go in the sacral woman game okay we have
to protect this carrot this is scary
protect don't shoot it now all there
convulse potatoes whatever whatever they
are they
yes stop shooting our Lord and Savior
Karen man help me Circle go into circle
I thought it was like cold beauty and I
could just I thought it was like on duty
you know when you're dressed you do a
posture tricolour yes yes so many herons
baby ah Karen and I hear lice bunny and
bunny Lee sonic great asses by the way
give me chips kara I was just trying to
kiss you
we are number one on the world line
Heights car the next game is called blue
know the rule a vocal was it's a game by
little you see you moves when I talk
whoo okay so people are gonna cross the
bridges and we need to have uh
I should be the last game of this
evening are you excited and save the
best for last
of course can you guess it then I owe
you go to Ikea IKEA simulator my mother
dinky assimilative oh by the sufferer do
you yeah what do you not do so what do I
do we build cake um we build furniture
together cool we need to make our
beautiful Hall Swedish Oh Freddy
I would never steal this is the slowest
turning I've seen in my life we're gonna
die before this IKEA table this is Emma
Oh
we built this table together together
forever around this table alright I'll
let you decide where we put it where
should we put it I'm trying
let's just put it this way because it
takes too much time
turn that was real it's see what is
these that I'm thinking oh batter that
is up to you to decide
probably said you know what it is yes
but it's really more about finding
yourself and where you are
that looks great though I think you
should do that how my weight foot table
on top of our light this game man this
game is great this is my favorite game
of all time
my connecting I generated this game 10
out of 10 Swedish meatballs which is a
really good and fair review I could
totally make this if I had a picture but
I don't know okay see this thing you
offend me so much by saying this dude if
you use the manual you might as well go
home even if you are home I wouldn't use
the manual I just have you said you
wanted the picture wait I want to know
what I'm building with the Mona Lisa
bailed from a picture no let me put the
book there that might be good oh yes now
press date no yes
that is a life that is a night yes
that's the right hole all right then
this has been a grain episode what great
furniture we built here today
proud of you for trying and thanks for
coming on the show
yeah leave a like if you enjoyed this
video and click here for more videos and
that's all you need to do thank you for
watching as always see why I say it's my
favorite game because I can change my
underwear
that'll dirty I'm going for the striped
ones cuz the striped shows off the girl
zeldo girls but